لقد فعلنا كل ما يلزم حقًا
للتأكد من أن الأشخاص الذين سيأتون إلى هنا
ليكونوا بأمان
أعتقد أننا أجرينا العديد من الاختبارات
للتأكد أيضًا من أننا مستعدون لذلك
في المطار ، حيث نستخدم أجهزة الكمبيوتر
الشخصية القادمة أو المغادرة
أيضًا لضمان الأشخاص الذين يعيشون هنا
، فإن سمعتنا هي التي نريد
التأكد
منها وكذلك حماية موظفينا حول
المطار
والمدينة لنشعر بسعادة كبيرة لفعل
ما
تعلموه على مدار السنوات التي تعلم فيها أنك
تعاملنا في الماضي مع
حرب الخليج أه حرب العراق في إيران
صدمة الأزمة المالية العالمية
الآن يقول الناس
إنه سيكون من الصعب جدًا على دبي أن
تستعيد عافيتها
كما تعلم أعتقد أن ما ذهبنا به
اكتشفنا 19 إنه مختلف عما
لدينا  مررت بأكثر من 30
عامًا أو 34 عامًا من
ممارسة الأعمال التجارية ، هذا هو ما تمثله أزمة عالمية ،
لكنني أعتقد أن العالم
بأسره سيتغلب عليها حقًا ، وأعتقد أننا
مهيئون
لأن لدينا التسهيلات التي لدينا
القوة البشرية ،
كل ما نحتاجه هناك للجلوس معنا  لقد
تم الاختبار
وأيضًا المرفق وكيف نرى حقًا عودة
نهر النشاط التجاري
ببطء ولكن بثبات